thank you ted today is national lasagna
day and we are celebrating
by showing you how to make a delicious
dish here to help us out is
leo landini the owner of landini's
pizzeria welcome to the studio
thank you this is great to be here okay
first off what ingredients do we need to
make the perfect dish
that's a great question so we start with
the lay of uh
pasta obviously then you start with then
you go with bechamel
that's my my little secret because a lot
of people put different ingredients but
the real lasagna has bechamel what is
it what is in this then so this is
pretty much a mix of flour
milk and salt and pepper so it makes it
you know
less heavy than ricotta cheese or other
cheeses that you see out there okay
so this is something that goes in the
real lasagna from bologna italy
and this is the next layer you've got
the pasta down so i did like a little
layer of butter then the pasta and then
a little parmesan you know italians we
put parmesan everywhere cheese it up
there you go so let's start making i
start assembling here we have the
finished product so start assembling
and talking about the ingredients you're
putting in correct it's fairly easy
jc so pretty much you go you know with a
little layer
of bechamel you know now when it comes
to the meat that you put in lasagna can
you can you get creative maybe use lamb
or something different can you get
creative with your meats you can get
creative you can put everything you want
honestly i mean this is a mix what we do
at landini we do a mix of different
meats so
pretty much it's a pork and
veal but you know you can use every sort
of meat you want you can even do
italian sausages if you like mix it up
just go with traditional meat just
make things up and get crazy yeah okay
what cheese we're putting on here so
this is mozzarella cheese
now also do you have a question we
always wanted when you're making lasagna
the pasta the layer of pasta is when
you're boiling that
should you put salt in that water as
well oh yeah that's the key
always don't ever make a pasta without
salt because you're wasting your time
that's a guarantee always put salt
always and don't be cheap load up on the
sauce i got a second layer of pasta
going in there
you go just sit it right here nice
then you go a little parmesan because
again we put parmesan even in the ice
cream anybody so
you put it on top of everything i do
have a question too when it comes to the
dish is this like a standard three-inch
dish that we're using does it matter how
big of a dish you use at home
you can go it depends how many layers
you want okay you know if you want a
lasagna like this you obviously need
a bigger one but you know this one
usually it's four or five you know
that's what we use
you know it's a good so we'll keep with
the thing is layer repeat layer repeat
and once we're done
we get this this is the finished product
correct tell me this looks like two
different lasagnas what are we looking
at all right so this is a vegetarian one
so you know we use uh depends what is in
season
so zucchini it's android tomatoes you
know i mean
red pepper green pepper whatever you
want you know you just put it there and
this one here
that is this guy here when it's finished
fantastic and he has a pizza as well he
brought us a bunch of red
so that's what we would known in san
diego for you know our new york
style pizza that's peanut cherry cottage
cheese that's
our uh yes
no that's actually italian sausages and
the red sauce and we call it cheese
beautiful
leo thank you so much for joining us as
you said we have to start a diet after
this segment and we'll eat
during the break las vegas now